plus que jamais l'Office Franco-Allemand
pour la Jeunesse souhaite placer le
cinéma au cœur de ces programmes
d'échange pour sensibiliser les jeunes à
l'engagement citoyen depuis 2005
l'ophage s'engage aux côtés de la
Semaine de la critique pour développer
l'esprit critique du jeune public à
travers des ateliers d'écriture des
projections de films les lycéens peuvent
également élargir leur culture
artistique écouter Anne Talino
secrétaire général de l'ophage de
manière générale nous sommes toujours
engagés dans le domaine culturel puisque
là on est dans les activités culturelles
mais ces dernières années avec encore
plus de force en effet il nous semble
que la culture est d'autant plus
importante aujourd'hui pour faire lien
entre nos sociétés c'est par le biais de
ces programmes culturels ou de ces
pratiques artistiques partagées que que
les jeunes découvrent la diversité de la
culture de l'autre s'en altérité
déconstruise des clichés qu'ils peuvent
nouer des liens extrêmement forts entre
eux ou bien la culture est aussi à
s'épanouir individuellement bien sûr au
total 20 lycéens d'Île-de-France
d'Occitanie et d'Allemagne ont pu
participer à ces ateliers parmi eux des
élèves du lycée Rosa Parks de Montgeron
dans l'Essonne dans l'académie de
Versailles d'abord nous essayons de
d'avoir au fil des années puisque ce
programme existe depuis 2005 l'ensemble
des régions en France et en Allemagne
qui sont représentés donc par exemple
l'année dernière il y avait déjà deux
Bretagne cette année on a regardé et
avons vu que ça faisait longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas eu de jeunes d'Île-de-France
des sons en l'occurrence et puis les
jeunes de Montpellier donc on nous
décidons entre nous donc en fonction de
ces critères et puis à l'intérieur des
académies on travaille avec les
académies et donc ce sont les
enseignants qui se manifestent auprès
des établissements pour dire qu'ils sont
partants et c'est eux qui choisissent
les jeunes une opération qui vise à
aiguiser le sens critique des jeunes
vis-à-vis des images et à poursuivre
leur éducation aux médias